On April 28th, 2025, I released a video
about Alzut, a strange people described
as tall, naked, and lean that met with
and mounted or rode the Muslim prophet
Muhammad all night long in a remote
desert spot. Yes, and as I mentioned
then, the Arabic word used in that
Hadith, Yarkabun, means to mount or ride
and carries the same dual meanings in
English. In formal usage, it means to
mount or ride, for example, a horse.
And in slang, it means to mount or ride,
typically a woman, but in the current
example, a man.
Anyway, I have since come to learn that
the Zot have become something of a
household name, or what they call a
meme.
Now, to be sure, this was never my
intention. If you watch my original
video, you'll see how I explain at the
very start that the only reason I was
documenting that troubling Hadith was in
the context of a debate I was then
involved in Muhammad's existence. My
point being, if Muhammad was a made-up
figure meant to be revered as a noble
prophet, why would those making him up
create such unflattering stories
surrounding him? At any rate, since that
video, I have been bombarded with
questions from viewers about Muhammad
and his sexuality, if there are other
Hadiths or accounts, what about Hadiths
against homosexuality, how do they fit
in, etc., etc. So, I've decided to
respond by making this mini-series aptly
titled The Zot Chronicles. My purpose is
threefold. First, and as mentioned, to
efficiently respond to those many
questions I've been receiving. Second,
and more importantly, to offer an
authoritative account on Islamic
sexuality, based as it is on Muhammad's
own sexuality, which we will be
examining in great detail. Finally, and
similar to why I made the original Zot
video, I'm creating this series to look
at the many contradictions of the
Hadith, how the Ulama, Islam scholars
and Sheikhs try to reconcile them, and
how it all manifests in Muslim societies
and practice, which of course is an
important question, not least as Islam's
presence continues to grow in the West.
To reiterate, I'm not doing this to poke
fun at Muhammad or mock Muslims, which
if you followed my work over the last
two decades, most of which does not deal
with Muhammad at all, you'll know it's
not something I care to do. In fact, the
last time I did a deep dive into
Muhammad's, how shall we say,
interesting sexuality was in a 2009
article I wrote titled The Perverse
Sexual Habits of the Prophet. And, as it
happens, virtually all of the Hadiths we
will be examining in this series were
first brought to a Western public in
that 17-year-old article. For a sneak
preview of what we'll be looking at,
feel free to check it out. I'll put a
link in the description.
Okay, brace yourself and get ready for
the ride. No pun intended.
[Music]